well i had a pretz omelette for
breakfast actually as well as a coffee
[Music]
so the prep index uh really tracks pretz
recovery through covid in
the markets that we operate in prep was
quite a bellwether uh through kovid in
regards to the impact of the brand you
know clearly it is a business that's
been built on urban centers and
transport locations which were the
busiest football locations before kovid
and became the quietest so we want to
share how pret is recovering
and clearly people saw how foot forward
returned or had retrenched when there
were different waves of
cove i'm very pleased to see
the recovery in europe i'd say as well
as the uk
uh i think that what we are seeing in
new york the recovery is slower
so people are not coming back to the
office
as they are in europe
and clearly
hong kong under
china's xero covid policy
is just a very different approach
what we have found as uh
the business has come back and our cells
have recovered
you know our supply chain ramp up has
been much more aggressive than if you're
operating a in a business as usual
rhythm and actually that's been apparent
uh for our competitors for grocery etc
so i think due to that it's been a real
challenging to
uh keep supply uh i do think things are
improving but we are still a way away
from it being
as strong as it was
before the pandemic
well i think in particular to see the
return of
travel in particular in the airports
we've seen a huge
come back there i think demand for
travel people getting out connecting
and being tourists has been much uh more
significant
than i would have expected
so before the pandemic probably the two
years before
we'd opened more stores outside of
london than inside london so that was
always
a natural progression but what we have
seen is that's definitely
accelerated our thinking through covid
so i think that
you know london has survived and thrived
for centuries and there has been many
pandemics through that time so
i think london will come back but it
will take time for london to come back